[Music]
fathers play a big role in their
daughter's life
it's a special bond that only they share
and even when she's all grown up she's
still daddy's little girl
[Music]
i have something to say i'm engaged
and
you proposed yes you proposed to him he
didn't propose to you can you do that
does anyone do that
you both have been coming here for over
a year do you still want this marriage
to work or not
i'm here now
[Music]
we're supposed to play the perfect
family until sophie gets married all we
can say sorry to spoil your happiness
but we're getting a divorce muscle tough
mommy happy this is alan castillo we
don't want some big fancy wedding and we
want to pay for it two lawyers are out
of college working for a non-profit
they're gonna pay for a wedding billy
i'm the father of the bride and i will
be paying for the wedding and i'm gonna
be walking my daughter down the aisle
the wedding planner see you in 20
minutes what are you planning
so what are we thinking about being
we don't want a catholic wedding what
are you talking about you can officiate
then my guide monica from the zen center
new york so a yoga class is set up a
wedding i caramba
this is my father for the wedding oh my
god how rick is this guy gonna have some
champagne and come aboard what is your
bond villain
we should go over the ground rules can
we all hands we can
can we dance if necessary how about
absolutely not
[Music]
daddy what is the budget that we're
working with
our mother
yes
i really like him he's nothing like us
maybe that's the point you don't watch
sports no i play sports i like hiking
things have been coming at me very fast
it's time for me to embrace the future i
got your back show time baby
[Applause]
[Music]
yes and you
no
[Music]
[Music]
you